hello everybody thanks for coming to my
webinar
for the laboratory automation and big
data section of this lab roots
presentation i'm going to be covering
comprehensive genomic association data
for genetic variant interpretation
walking through denominator's
computational approach
to facilitate varying interpretation in
both the clinic
and in pharmaceutical research and
discovery
so my name is mark heal i'm an md phd
with a background in molecular genetic
pathology
and i am the founder and chief science
officer of genomic
and we provide evidence-based genomic
association data
to the clinic and to pharma to drive
precision medicine
so at a very high level the the subjects
that i want to touch on
today are the why how and what
of expediting through big data
genetic variant interpretation by
beginning
with talking about big data applications
specifically in the context of genomics
then discussing
how we bring that data to bear to
provide value
by talking a little bit about genomics
flagship product mastermind
and how it is driven from an automation
and computational perspective
by genomic language processing and then
finally i'll end the presentation by
talking through several representative
use cases
at various levels of genetic variants
that are encountered in clinic
and in pharmaceutical research so let me
say that mastermind as a search engine
is freely available
in its basic edition and that through
this uh
arrangement with labrus you can get
access to a trial version of mastermind
professional
which is used in clinical circumstances
and has a number of feature-rich
components that help drive the
sensitivity and specificity
of your evidence search in the clinic if
you just follow that bitly link below
mm lab routes 2020 you should be
afforded access to the professional
trial
but let me begin by talking about big
data applications in genomics
and set a landscape view by talking to
what is needed
to fully inform precision medicine
studies particularly in the context of
genomics and the answer
writ large is a comprehensive
understanding
of genomic biology biomarkers and all of
the attendant evidence
necessary to ensure maximally sensitive
and accurate
understanding of those biomarkers and
you can break this down into three
high-level flavors that are commonly
encountered
in molecular diagnostics that is to say
diagnostics themselves and that is
clinical grade
industry standard uh varying
interpretation guidelines to ensure
fidelity and accuracy and
comprehensiveness of an interpretation
as well as to understand pathogen
pathogenicity
in the form of the empirical studies
that suggest what the function of these
genetic variants are
by by individually characterizing each
of these variants
with the prevailing evidence in the
empirical literature
and then finally the culmination of all
this work is to
inform treatment strategies in the
clinic or in pharmaceutical
research and development by providing
all of the documentary evidence
necessary to inform some of those early
drug development
strategies and approaches as well as
toward the end of the drug
pipeline culminating in the design and
conduct of clinical trials
so that's what's needed to drive uh the
full combination of precision medicine
studies through genomics
but the challenge is that extracting
and organizing and interpreting all of
this genetic information
requires human intervention to both
assemble that data as well as to
interpret that data
and that has intrinsic limitations
towards scaling
genomic medicine in the clinic this
problem has been referred to as the
million-dollar interpretation
when juxtaposed in the face of
precipitously decreasing costs of
producing this data
in the form of say the thousand dollar
genome which
five or ten years ago was just a
futuristic pipe dream
what we're now seeing is that sequencing
is commoditized
but the challenges associated with
interpreting this data
has remained relatively static absent a
solution that we're going to be
discussing
like mastermind powered by its genomic
language processing
similarly on the pharma side there are
challenges associated with the human
need
to organize all of this evidence and
preventing efficiency of organization of
that data and also
perhaps missing critical components that
could unlock
future discoveries and this is
exemplified in this quote from
a recent review from nature genetics
that indicates that
genetically supported targets double the
success rate
of drugs that culminate in
commercial and clinical success and so
both in the clinic
and in pharma there's a real benefit
to having all of this information
pre-ordained
pre-organized pre-annotated and then
allowing
the human reviewers of those data to
perform the cerebral work of finalizing
that interpretation
and leaving the muscular work to the the
machines and the algorithms
who are expertly trained in that
capability
so some of the specific barriers to
scaling both of these
uh different aspects of genomic medicine
in the clinic and in pharma are that
there's just a lot of information
so there's an information glut which is
a great potential benefit
but absent a streamlined ability to
access and organize this information
it becomes a significant challenge and
not only is there too much of this
information
but it is largely unstructured
particularly when we're talking about
the lion's share of empirical data which
is patterned in the published literature
when we're talking about clinical
medicine and uh
the aspects of clinical variant
interpretation that are applicable
to pharma r d there are
standard interpretation guidelines to
regularize and make more reproducible
varying interpretation but you can
imagine how complex
and sometimes idiosyncratic those
guidelines can be
and how they draw on varied sources of
information
which poses its own unique set of
challenges and so
the fact that there are guidelines are
fantastic
but from a computational perspective
that means that those guidelines need to
be adhered to
when you're organizing and assembling
and annotating this data
and lastly uh particularly in clinical
medicine
there are um there is the need to have
these uh pipelines
that go from raw data or even further to
raw patient samples all the way through
to this
final interpretation and that requires a
synchrony
and an integration across multiple
different aspects of that pipeline
and that adds to and compounds the
challenges that i'm referring to here
when we're talking about scaling genomic
medicine
so let's talk now about how phenomenon
through mastermind and through genomic
language processing
is surmounting these barriers and rising
to this challenge
to fully scale and maximize the value
of genetic and genomic clinical medicine
and research so this is
a new way for us to present the value
that we provide
to our clinical clients and to our
pharma partners
and that is to say uh as i mentioned
earlier that we traffic in
genetic and genomic evidence but uh to
put a finer point on it
we surface genomic association data
and those varied associations come in
varieties that i'm highlighting here
in in the diagram on the left where you
can see
different biological concepts and how
they may be interconnected with one
another or
among themselves so for instance a gene
and a variant can be
certainly tied to a disease a monogenic
or a polygenic disease whether it be
cancer or constitutional
but likewise it can be associated with a
particular therapy
or a specific phenotype in the case
where a
diagnostic disease is
is not apparent the phenotypes that are
seen in your patient
may lead the way toward a specific gene
or variant that is the ultimate cause
mastermind through its genomic language
processing
makes all of those connections and
annotate
annotates and specifies those
connections
through categorized keyword
uh annotations of all of those
associations as well
and the benefit of having that manifold
genomic association network is that
the stronger the association
the more likely you are to see multiple
of those connections
for instance there's a strength in
finding a therapy that's targeted to a
specific disease
but that association becomes even more
deeply connected
and verifiable when you add a gene or a
gene invariant
or further when you add additional
phenotypes and categorical
terms to it and so those
strong associations get even stronger
the deeper those biological concepts can
connect with one another
and that's the high value genetic
insight that genomic through mastermind
and its glp
or genomic language processing brings
into the clinic and into pharma research
so the two ways that i've conceptualized
here the insight that we provide
being first organizing all of that
evidence again predicated on the
entirety of the medical literature
in a way that's imminently searchable
and organizable
but then also surfacing otherwise
unknown association data so
having the benefit of this comprehensive
view
and comprehensive indexing of all of
that empirical evidence allows us to see
things
that are otherwise opaque um
in other platforms or in other users
hands
and so just to be more specific
mastermind is a
genomic search engine powered by genomic
evidence
that spans the gamut of human disease
across all
genes and all variants and all variant
types
across all of genetics and decorates all
of that data
with phenotypes therapies and any
category
uh key terms or custom searches that the
user has
um uh in their purview
just uh to take you behind the scenes a
little bit into the software itself two
salient value propositions for
mastermind are its comprehensive
reach into the variant landscape of any
one of those genes in the human genome
where we can present all of that
information in its totality
so that it can be searched one by one or
you can look at it as more of a
landscape
view to see all of that data all at once
but then providing the granular level of
information
in the form of reference citations at
the top right
or their specific sentence context where
any of these terms
genes variants categorical key terms
phenotypes etc are mentioned
you can see how we produce the evidence
supporting those automated calls from
our glp data assembly process
uh a summary of the content in
mastermind
is that we include in our offerings for
pharma
and for the clinical users both
population data and in silicon models of
pathogenicity as well as the empirical
evidence
and all of this data covers gene level
variant level
and disease and drug information as well
and
uh the main takeaway here is that we
have the most comprehensive offering of
this genetic and genomic information
so part of the the intent of this
conversation with you is to take you
behind the scenes
and showcase how we're doing that using
uh the the guiding principles of
genomics genomic language processing
so bear with me i have a number of
slides that iterate here
where i'm going to speak to what that
principle is and give you a specific
representation of how we employ that
principle to develop genomic language
processing
so the first here is striking a balance
between
sensitivity and specificity when you're
using computational approaches
to data based automation and data
annotation so sensitivity i like to say
finding everything you need
and specificity means and nothing you
don't
so being sure that you're not missing
anything but you're also not including
too many things that are irrelevant
and the first example that i'm including
here is the the substrate of your
your indexing so what data are you
looking through
to begin with and that comes in a couple
of flavors here
there's obvious uh value in titles and
abstracts when we're talking about
the medical literature specifically but
then particularly for genetics and
genomics
there's a rich body of information
that's only patterned at the full text
level often in figures and tables
and increasingly with large scale next
generation sequencing data sets
only in the supplemental data and
mastermind covers
all of those different data substrates
and does so
exhaustively and and prioritizes the
data according to
where and to what extent that
information is present in any one of
those references
so that's the first measure of the
sensitivity
in our genomic language processing
approach the next thing is
the the granules of information in any
one of those sources title abstract full
text or supplemental data
and one example here is in our nuanced
approach to text
conversion so it's hard to see here but
what
what i'm highlighting there is a
particular variant and the way that it's
represented by this individual author
and the challenges that are attended
with
reconciling the way that that
information is patterned
in the actual data substrate itself so
this is a computer's eye view of what
that
reference uh was citing which is to say
a specific genetic variant and there's
probably 25 different ways to represent
a delta character
which can sometimes be used to describe
a specific genetic variant
when this is what a human viewer of that
information would see
one aspect of genomic language
processing is
to put the computer in the place of the
human
and see the the data as it's rendered
just as a human would and so we have
developed special techniques
that perform character conversion based
on um
optical character recognition by mapping
those special characters into a bitmap
and then translating that into the most
likely match
as would be recognized by a human
observer so again that's talking about
sensitivity
making sure that you're not missing
those necessary
special characters another
facet of genomic language processing
that may be familiar to those of you who
know about natural language processing
is named entity recognition
simple examples that i'm highlighting
here would be diseases and phenotypes
some ontologies that capture disease
information and phenotype
information ontologies or dictionaries
of terms with key
value pairs are freely available to use
including medical subject heading terms
for diseases and the human phenotype
ontology for phenotypes
and those happen to be widely used
across clinical medicine and pharma
research
and so when we're talking about the
specificity of the search results
we wanted to start where there was the
most clinical
and research currency and so we began
with those
freely available open source ontologies
similarly when we're talking about named
entity recognition for genes
there is a whole consortia or committee
of individuals geneticists and the like
who are charged with uh specifically
naming
these different gene entities with
symbols and their representative
synonyms
and when we're talking about the
entirety of the empirical literature
as we are indexing we have to take into
account previous
aliases and nicknames and synonyms and
so we span the gamut in time
from retired synonyms as well as current
accepted symbols
to be sure that we're maximally
sensitive
i think the last facet of sensitivity
and specificity that i want to speak to
is the most complicated and that is to
say how
variants can be described and similar to
the hgnc
gene naming committee there is a human
genome variation society which has
codified
the most appropriate way to accurately
name genetic variants
and so that's the fantastic organization
who is doing great work
unfortunately not every author is
faithful to the hgbs
system nor do they always get it right
if they try
nor are articles that cite variants from
decades ago
faithful to those newly codified
nomenclature rules and so
the onus is on uh glp and mastermind to
be sure that we're not leaving any of
those
previous or otherwise non-standard
nomenclatures
unfound and so to enhance the
sensitivity of our search
we pay very particular attention to the
myriad different ways that authors can
describe variants
whether they're appropriate or less so
a couple of other components here are
the difference between
pattern recognition and semantic meaning
and our guiding principle here is by
starting to
just simply identify what's important
and leaving the interpretation of what
it means
to the human reviewers who use our
software
or otherwise who are internal to
phenomenon and develop
these very large data sets for our
pharma clients
and so we we recognized very early
that there are a lot of challenges in
getting semantic meaning correct
particularly when you're talking about
the context of scientific meaning
but that eighty percent of the value
comes from simply accurately recognizing
the right entities and then recognizing
them in their context
so we've assured the the need to
interpret the semantics and the meaning
in favor of
accurate and and uh comprehensive
recognition of
the entities and their the context in
which they appear
and leave the interpretation to the
human reviewer
another facet of glp is the the
trade-off between filtration or throwing
away things that you're presuming in
your algorithms aren't important
versus prioritization and so
particularly when we're talking about um
scientific evidence
and and uh text and data mining there's
different uh value that a
one user might approach the the question
with
than any other given user and so
different filtration strategies
may be less appropriate depending on
context
whereas a real time prioritization
strategy
will allow the user more flexibility in
surfacing
in real time what aspect of what they're
looking for is important to them
and you you're less likely to run the
risk of throwing something
away that's important which obviously in
clinical medicine can be extremely
deleterious
similarly there's there's ways to to
levels at which you can recognize what
might be a mechanism to prioritize the
data
it may be say a specific journal which
has different types of content a new
england journal of medicine
versus a journal of biological chemistry
obviously they have different audiences
and different mandates and
different areas of focus and that can be
one mechanism by which you prioritize
what a user
is looking to see there's also the
article level where you talk about what
the content of that article is which you
can infer
by the title by the abstract and by all
of the information content
in the full text and supplemental data
and you can you can
shrink that down and make it more
granular by talking about the content of
a paragraph or even a specific sentence
at the same time then that you can
prioritize the data
based on a gene that you've actually
searched for or related genes in a
pathway
or the specific variant that you were
looking for or a widely cited variant
that you weren't necessarily looking for
in your search
or related variants to a variant that
you search for
if say there's no information for that
search for variant
and so those are some of the different
strategies that we invoke in our glp
to prioritize the data that we surface
additional features that we invoke for
prioritization include
how many times a term is mentioned where
it's mentioned and next to what
additional terms
what context is that uh citation or the
named entity recognized in what sentence
paragraph
section of a publication or what have
you how how well cited is that article
and how recent is that article or other
mechanisms that we invoke to prioritize
the data
we always show our work so there's been
a lot of press
lately about the the opacity of
artificial intelligence algorithms
and how it's very difficult to penetrate
what they mean
when you're trying to adjudicate how
accurate they are
and our approach has always been show
your work provide the evidence
particularly in a clinical setting
to justify any scientific assertion that
the algorithm is making
for the human reviewer to uh to assess
with their experience we also
uh have a healthy balance between the
specific
bottom-up approach where we know what we
can
find very specifically versus taking a
more
nebulous general approach again using
some of those black box ai techniques
we like to focus on things that we know
are specific and specifically valuable
the example of which i'm showing there
are those named entity variants that we
recognize
in all of their different nomenclatures
and then again i want to emphasize here
that we
have taken the approach of striving to
replicate the human curation process
as opposed to taking a black box
approach
and devising algorithms that don't
recapitulate what the human already does
and that therefore would be very hard
for a human to interpret
the validity of and so by no means as
genomics gop
intended to to replace the human process
rather it's intended to expedite the
human curation process
by following their paradigm uh
whether they're codified in uh those
guidelines that i talked about
or whether they're patterned in the
user's own search
but to as faithfully as we can
recapitulate
what a human would do to go through and
adjudicate the value of any of that
information
but just do so at a hundred or a
thousand x scale
so the algorithms that we invoke are are
attempting to be faithful to the human
process
just infinitely faster but in a way that
the results can be readily interpreted
by the human user
so in the last uh section of the webinar
i want to go through some representative
use cases
the way that i've broken this
information out here these use cases
is by talking about the different types
of genetic lesions
that our glp is able to organize and
present evidence for
and how how that can provide value in
clinical and research contexts
so i'll begin by talking about fusion
gene data
then i'll talk about another structural
variant copy number
uh variance then i'll talk about smaller
variants like indels and single
nucleotide changes
and then i'll end by talking about how
we can do that
database assembly from our gop and
genomic association
indexing capability at scale
so let's first talk about the use case
of identifying fusion genes
just as a proof of concept here we've
begun in this approach
with the 500 or so genes that comprise
the illumina true sight rna fusion panel
so these are genes that when involved in
a fusion gene event from a large
chromosomal
disruption can lead to novel and
deleterious biological function
that can can be treated or can be used
for for diagnostic purposes
in the case of alumina this is for
oncology cancer-related diseases so for
any one of those 500
or so genes we asked mastermind
what are the fusion genes that are
partnered with each of those
driver genes and we asked how many of
those different gene fusion events
could we characterize with our glp and
from
how many references did that information
come and you can see the result there on
the right
that for any one of those 500 or so
input genes
mastermind through its gop was able to
recognize between
1 and 95 unique fusion partners
for each of those different genes which
resulted
all in for those 507 genes in about 2500
unique gene fusion events and when i say
unique i mean to say
gene a to gene b where that
that particular unique fusion event may
have any one of a number of different
break points but we counted each of
those together as just one fusion event
and all of that information came from
the automated indexing
of nearly 30 000 articles after sifting
through many millions of articles in our
database
to identify the content that is most
likely to be talking about
gene fusion data and that mentions gene
a
and gb no matter what gene a and gene b
are
an appropriate sentence and paragraph
and article context
that indicates that these are actual
fusion genes
and all of this information was
automatically assembled using
mastermind's gop but then exhaustively
manually reviewed
to check the evidence just as i talked
about one of the guiding principles
favoring the human interpretation
over a black box algorithmic
assessment and so this is the the
takeaway from that work
where i'm comparing in this diagram
uh for each input gene that on the
x-axis the number of unique fusion
partners
that were identified by mastermind in
blue or
the prevailing manually curated database
cosmic
and you can see how dramatically
mastermind has outstripped
the number of unique fusion partners
that were identified
using this gop approach and the reason
that that's beneficial i'm highlighting
here
by by showcasing that for this
particular data set that we assembled
for one input gene which is mpm1
there was a fusion event called uh that
led to a juxtaposition of npm one
and tick two that was not present in
cosmic
but that nevertheless had nine
references that
cited its uh oncologic potential
and indeed not only was it a driver
fusion event that it drove the large
proportion
of a particular type of cancer for which
there is a targeted therapy
so this isn't just an academic exercise
with hypothetical value
there's any one of a number of patients
who may have this
fusion mutation that if you didn't have
the information for as a clinician
would be lost on you and that patient
would not receive
an appropriate treatment so
another type of structural alteration is
copy number variance
this posed a unique set of challenges
for glp
because copy number variants can be
described at multiple levels
just to orient you what a copy number
variant is it's a
a sufficiently large section of a
chromosome
that is either deleted or amplified and
the challenge from a computational
perspective
is that those nomenclatures that authors
can use to describe those copy number
variants
can come in as many as five different
flavors without
any standardization among them and so
the challenge that we set to ourselves
was
flexibly and comprehensively recognizing
all of the different ways that any one
of those copy number variants can be
cited and then automating the assembly
of any of that information for any
user's input for any type of copy number
variant
and what i've done here in this schema
for representative copy number variants
at the
chromosomal cytoband level as you can
see there with 11q23
on a log scale i'm i'm showcasing
how many references citing those
particular copy number variants
were found by mastermind as compared to
a standard pubmed search
which is the the go-to or the previous
go-to source for this information
and i'll point out here that the y-axis
is on a log scale
so you can see that for each of these
there's a at least an order of magnitude
more references
and therefore more occasions to find
meaningful associations such as
therapeutic approaches
or functional insight that will will
allow
researchers to define what's actually
going on when one of these cytobans is
deleted or amplified
in a particular patient so just like we
talked about with fusion
the glp approach which is indeed
fatigable
and can be tuned for maximal sensitivity
and specificity
dramatically improved any manual
approach
to identifying this evidence so the
the um the next example that i'm going
to go through is for single nucleotide
or small indel variants
just to orient you uh about the
meaningfulness of this slide
this is a reflection of the sensitivity
of evincing which references are
cited from different sources be they
mastermind or other search resources
like google scholar pubmed or clinvar
what you're seeing here is for each of
those resources
we're sorting by the sensitivity on a
per
variant basis where if all of the
references that were found in any one of
these resources
were found by one of those resources the
sensitivity would be 100
and that's broken down for each
individual variant again
in sorted order for each of those
resources so what you're looking for
for the quality of the resource is
a nice right angle that repletes that
rectangle with a maximum
area under the curve and a poor quality
resource
would be hugging the lower left axis
there
and what you can see is that for the
vast majority of variants more than 90
of the variants that were tested in this
example of randomly selected clinical
variants
mastermind had 100 of any of the
references that were identified by any
one of the sources
whereas when you look at say pubmed
pubmed
missed more than 50 of the references
in almost all of the variant searches
and google scholar and another resource
known as clinvar which is manually
assembled
by uh by user submission is missing
about
half of the evidence for any one of
those variants that we were discussing
earlier
which as i as i mentioned before can
mean the difference between
a diagnosis and not a diagnosis
or a treatment and and a lack of
treatment for a particular patient
so the last example that i want to walk
through is how we can
employ our ability to index and
aggregate all of this annotated
information
at scale to produce manually curated
comprehensive genomic landscapes this is
a diagram diagram that walks through
that process
the top part speaks to our computational
intelligence and machine learning
capability to organize that information
but then it completes by having
final expert manual human curation
and review so we have at genomicon a
very unique
two-pronged approach where we maximize
the potential
of computational intelligence but uh
maximize the benefit of human level
curation
just do so in extremely high throughput
and what one of those genomic landscapes
look looks like i'm showcasing here with
an example for ref
where our process was invoked to
comprehensively identify
and curate the evidence for leading to
an interpretation
for any one of the variants in ref
as being pathogenic and even qualifying
which of those variants are known to be
activating and therefore amenable to
treatment
and just like i talked about in our
guiding principles we show all of our
work
and every scientific assertion is backed
by the source
evidence the source of truth the
reference
from which that assertion was made as
you can see here
where that information is all tiered
with
the peak being the the final call and
the base being all of this
reference cited evidence that was
manually curated
what that results in as i'm showcasing
here is
a dramatic increase in this case it's
three and a half fold though in many
circumstances we go
10 or 20 fold a broader awareness of
disease-causing variance
any one of which could be linked to a
patient any one of which can mean the
difference between treatment or absence
of a treatment
and we're just exemplifying that in this
plot at the top is
the status before when we were engaged
by the pharma client
after many years of manual curation they
were able to identify a couple dozen
activating variants and within a matter
of weeks we were able to
increase that by at least 100 variants
which you're seeing there
at the bottom diagram in blue and i like
this plot because it showcases the idea
that only with a comprehensive view of
all of the variants
are you able to see salient patterns
emerge
in the places where these variants
affect the protein
and therefore what they may be doing to
the protein and therefore
may guide uh downstream research and
development of different drug programs
so this is a summary slide that speaks
to some of the genes just a
representative sample of some of the
genes that we have curated
and their yield when we produce the
comprehensive genomic landscapes
compared to the yield that you'd get
from a conventionally developed manually
curated database
such as clinvar so you can see the range
there
is from a few percent more variants that
were identified
all the way up to 15 fold more
driver mutations with all of the
evidence predicate
so that you you can appreciate the
accuracy of those interpretations
uh i'll conclude here by emphasizing
again that mastermind the search engine
is available to you
um for for basic users to guide research
uh for free you can sign up through
that link below but also through our
relationship with labruz
you'll be afforded trial access of
mastermind pro which is useful in
clinical circumstances
and so with that i'll adjourn but i'll
indicate that you can reach out to us
uh specifically at hello genominon.com
or otherwise through the labyrinths
event
if you've got specific questions about
glp or the content that i've
talked about in this presentation thank
you for your time